now on Tuesday the charity nordorf
Robbins is hosting its annual Christmas
Carol service which is also a fundraiser
for the UK's largest music therapy
charity and joining me now is chief
executive of nordorf Robbins Sandra
schembry along with Mervin Lin who's a
trustee and his daughter Sia also
received music therapy at nordorf Robins
so a very good morning to both of you
and welcome and I'll find out a little
bit about what you've got in store for
this carol service in a moment at Sandra
shenbury but let's first of all explain
why you're raising money what nordorf
Robbins is and what music therapy is not
a problem at all so
music speaks for a word for words fail
so most of our clients are non-verbal
and they have multiple challenges which
leads to incredible isolation
music for some of our clients is the
only thing that is able to break through
and actually helps them be in the world
and see the world and engage and that
might be
um uh Kath with her daughter who um she
said to us her home had been signed up
for five years but through music therapy
her daughter had managed to engage
enough to want to make music and then to
actually make sounds so now her daughter
she said the house is very loud again
and that was done through music and
again if you think about the first
things we hear um when you're in your in
the womb it's the noise of the swooshing
of the blood and the heartbeat so that's
why the rhythm is so important so
innately we understand music so it's
able to connect to parts that otherwise
um someone might not be able to engage
with that's so interesting and Mervyn
you've seen haven't you the effects that
music therapy can have through your
daughter tell us a little bit about her
experience of music therapy
um well she is now 21 and she started
seizing when she was two and has been on
a steady decline since then the the
seizures
kind of
eroded her memory and and her motor
skills and pretty much can't do anything
herself
the only thing that she has any
connection with really is you know music
therapy sessions where there's a
connection still there's still a bridge
that you know that can be crossed that
is that kind of gives her the
satisfaction that she gets she gets
nowhere else so give us an idea of how
she does respond during a session
um well on a good day when she's you
know she's been three or four days
without seizure she she does the rocking
and you know like this which you know
she doesn't do normally you know she's
she's pretty
you know she's she's non-verbal she just
pretty much sits and watches her DVDs
when she can and you I have to feed her
you know and she has a tube but with her
music therapy she she definitely does
the the collection and and then she's
holding something like a pencil or a or
a drumstick she'll you know not in time
but she'll be yeah but she'll be yeah
she'll be interacting it's amazing isn't
it and Sandra it does it can reach lots
of different people obviously Sears
experiences one but they're you know
people with addiction people with
dementia it can make a real difference
to people can't it absolutely
um uh we talk about life phase so from
from birth to death
um music is able to connect in ways
whether that's through trauma as you say
or addiction or
um dementia there it wherever someone is
isolated from the world music for some
reason is able to get through yeah but
what is the reason I mean you talked
about that kind of primal thing of
having the you know in the womb that we
hear rhythms but this has something else
about music that communicates in a way
that speech sometimes doesn't it's
there's a there's an understanding of it
bodily not just mentally so actually
there's a physicality to it and there is
something about reaching out with music
that enables someone to connect in a way
that isn't just words we're so Reliant
if one can speak on the words that we
say in the language we give that we
forget that language is much much much
more than that and music is able to
Encompass all of that so it gives
someone a root in that they aren't able
to find elsewhere that's so interesting
and give us a sense of what a session
looks like uh for Sia for example I mean
obviously each session is going to be
different depending on who therapist is
dealing with but what kind of um
where on C and see a seizure cycle she
is so the further away from the seizures
the more interactive she is but
obviously if she's just had a seizure
the day before a couple of days before
she's still very sedate
um but um but it's hard to describe the
connection until you see something to
compare it with so if you see her
normally it's she's pretty non you know
non-interactive really that the world is
a complete blur to her but in that
session where there's attention to her
that someone is you know singing to her
talking to her in such a way that is you
know rhythmic
um yeah there is a connection there and
I'm not quite I'm not quite sure
far more eloquently than I do but there
is a there is a a connection there which
is non-visible but it's it's certainly
there do you have to be Musical to get
benefits from it no absolutely but
technically we would say everyone is
musicals anyone that comes to us and
says I don't do music it's like let's
see shall we that's interesting but
there's also a connection sometimes on a
very deep personal level which can be
done through breathing like if you find
yourself son if you have a loved one
over Christmas that actually they're
disconnected for the reason it might be
a family member of the dementia
sit beside them and breathe with them
like that simple Act of breathing in I'm
getting Goosebumps thinking about it in
time
it might they they might recognize that
you're breathing with them and you're
attuning to them and that and you never
know what might come from that and just
it just needs to be two minutes it
doesn't need to be
um for a long time but just that it's
connect how you can
it's Rhythm and connection very briefly
your Carousel yeah some big names at it
we do and we've released some tickets
just for today because we know we're
coming on
um uh Nar Rogers uh is going to come on
with Chic amazing for us Richie Sambora
we've got some incredible speakers as
well so yes if you can please come
is amazing anyway good luck with that
lovely to meet you both thanks so much
for coming in thank you